a wild night for firefighters up in the
northwest valley for nearly 12 hours
crews have been working to put out a
massive building fire at the shuttered
silverstone golf course
sashaloft has been there the entire time
spoke to those who live in the nearby
area they say this is a culmination of
many past issues
brian it has been a long night and you
can see firefighters are still attacking
what's left of this fire nearly 12 hours
after it started but those who live
nearby say this building has been an
issue for a lot longer and they'd like
to see something done about it
orange flames pierce the night sky as a
smoky haze envelops northwest las vegas
oh my gosh right close to our houses
it's quite scary it looks like a scene
from a movie but it's actually the
intense reality of what once was the
silverstone golf club burning to the
ground it's just an ongoing nuisance
it's becoming a menace the property and
the 27 hole course it connects to
shuttered back in 2015 and those who
live nearby say it's brought nothing but
trouble since then i know that there
have been squatters and homeless people
that have stayed there as you can see we
got
pretty well everybody back away from the
building tim cemanski of las vegas fire
and rescue says the building also made
things tough for firefighters who spent
hours slowly attacking the flames from
the outside this fire was always in
charge and we went on the defense and
that means we didn't want it to get out
and around out of the area as for those
in this neighborhood they're glad no one
was hurt but they hope this terrifying
turn of events what frustrates us is
that nothing is being done will lead to
some much needed growth and change on
their street something to better our
community
no word on an official cause just yet
but damage is estimated around 5 million
dollars you can see kind of the rubble
and debris spilling out of the front of
the building there now fire crews are
expected to stay out here for a while
longer and continue to put out the rest
of these hot spots we're told up through
saturday morning reporting live tonight
sasha loftis live local now